Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wenn Sie etwas nie verstehen, können Sie bitte am Ende des Gesprächs oder zwischendurch Ihre Frage stellen.
Okay.
Ja, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Ilona Mezeburg.
Ilona?
Mezeburg.
Mezeburg. Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname langen Bursch darüber?
Ilona schreibt sich I-L-O-N-A.
Mezeburg schreibt sich M-E-S-E-B-U-R-G.
Okay. Frau Mezeburg.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
30 Jahre alt?
30 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie hier?
Am 12. März 1992.
Okay. Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Mezeburg?
63 kg.
Wie bitte?
Und wie lange sind Sie hier?
Frau Mezeburg.
Ich habe seit zwei Tagen Bauchschmerzen.
Und die haben in den letzten Stunden, in der letzten Nacht,
haben die zugenommen.
Es ist schlimmer geworden.
Das muss ich untersuchen lassen.
Wo genau, ob bei Bauch oder mit Bauch?
Ja.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen mehr, wie hier rechts unten im Bauch.
Am Anfang waren Sie mehr so um den Bauchnabel rum.
Da haben Sie begonnen in der Mitte.
Und dann sind Sie seit gestern nach rechts unten bezogen.
Ja. Sie meinen, seit gestern Abend sind die Schmerzen
in den rechten Unterseiten ausgesteuert.
Ja, in den rechten Unterbauch.
Okay.
Wie können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie drückend?
Ja, es ist mehr drückend, aber manchmal auch so etwas krampfartig.
Meistens aber einen Druck mehr.
Und haben Sie diese ähnliche Beschwerde früher gehabt?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ja, früher.
Und wichtig sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalaphone 1 bis 10.
Wobei ein sehr lecker Schmerz und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen ist.
Wenn so ein Krampf dazu kommt, sieben.
Sieben.
So 6 bis 7, ja.
Und sind die Schmerzen immer da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Ja, sie sind immer da.
Ein Druckschmerz ist immer da und manchmal kommt so ein Krampf.
Ja.
Und gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser,
dass die Schmerzen lehnt oder verstärkt?
Also ich habe heute Morgen noch eine Wärmflasche auf den Bauch gelegt
und das war nicht so gut.
Das wurde schlimm.
Ja.
Und wenn Sie etwas essen oder trinken, sind die Schmerzen?
Ich habe zurzeit keinen Appetit.
Mir ist auch übel und ich habe so etwas Brechreiz, aber noch nicht gebrochen.
Aber Appetit habe ich nicht.
Ich habe etwas getrunken, etwas Tee.
Ja, Sie trinken nur Tee.
Sie essen gar nicht, ja.
Ich habe in den letzten 12, 14 Stunden nichts gegessen,
hatte ich keinen Appetit.
Okay, Frau Mezebuck, gibt es noch etwas Beschwerden
außer diese Beschwerden?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe eben Fieber gemessen.
Ja, ja, haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, 38,5.
38,5.
Wann haben Sie gemessen?
Vor zwei Stunden.
Ja, sind Sie, ja, oder fühlen Sie sich, Fieber, heute oder seit zwei Tagen auch?
Ja, das ist, am Anfang war das noch nicht mit dem Fieber.
Das ist jetzt so gekommen.
Deswegen habe ich heute mal gemessen.
Heute Nacht, dann fühlte ich mich so etwas, dass es so warm war.
Aber ich glaube, schon vom Gefühl habe ich jetzt auch weiter Fieber.
Ja, okay.
Frau Mezebuck, haben Sie Stuhlproz oder Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Okay, und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Und hat sich, ja, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit,
ja, ungefähr sechs Monate, in sechs Monaten,
ungewirrt ab oder zu genommen?
Vom Gewicht, ja, abgenommen?
Ja, ja.
Nein, das habe ich immer gehalten, das Gewicht.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Nein, ich habe nicht mal.
In meinem Beruf als Lehrerin gibt es manchmal Stress.
Dann kann ich nicht so gut schlafen, aber das ist nicht immer.
Ja, schön.
Ja, okay.
Und gibt es irgendeine Wichtige Vorerkrankungen?
Haben Sie Wichtige Vorerkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Zum Beispiel Blutortruck oder Blutstück?
Ja, Blutdruck, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Ja, manchmal zu niedrigen Blutdruck.
Ich habe eine Schildrüse unter Funktionen seit 15 Jahren
und dann nehme ich eine Tablette für einen.
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme Tyrona Jodd.
Tyrona Jodd 50.
Einmal.
Einmal morgens, ja.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich wurde schon mal operiert.
Als Kind, da war ich neun Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Und reagieren Sie allergisch,
irgendeine Medikamente oder Lebensmittel?
Medikamente nicht, aber was ich nicht vertrage,
ist Kiwi und Erdbeer.
Ich vertrage nicht, da kriege ich Ausschlag im Mund, Bläschen.
Kiwi und Erdbeer, ja.
Ja, das äußere sich Hautausschlag.
Ja, im Mund.
Ja, und Schleimhaut, da gibt es so Bläschen und das Brett.
Sind Sie gegen Coronavirus vollständig gehängt?
Ich habe drei Impfungen.
Ich habe Corona gehabt im April.
Im April.
Das war aber gut verlaufen.
Ja, gut verlaufen, ja, sehr schön.
Sind Sie gegen Kindheit, Krankheiten,
gegen Kindheit, Krankheiten aufgehängt?
Gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, die übliche Impfung habe ich alle bekommen beim Kinderhalt.
Und auch jetzt aufrisch Impfungen gegen Wunschtag,
Krampf und Keuchusen und Pifterie, das habe ich alles bekommen.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und waren Sie schon einmal im Ausland, im letzter Zeit, mein Name?
Ich war vor zwei Monaten, war ich für eine Woche in Italien.
Ja.
Rauchen Sie Frau Mehlib?
Ja, sehr schön.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal trinke ich ein Glas Wein, vielleicht in der Woche zwei Gläser.
Nur am Wochenende.
Wie bitte?
Nur am Wochenende, oder?
Ja, manchmal.
Aber mehr als zwei Gläser nicht.
Ja, okay, sehr schön.
Und das ist eine Routinefrage.
Ich muss auch fragen, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, ich nehme keine.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und sind Ihre Blutung, Regelblutung, Regelmessig?
Ja.
Ich gehe auch regelmäßig zur Gynäkologin, da ist natürlich alles in Ordnung.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Mein Vater, der ist 62 Jahre alt, der hat eine chronische Bronchitis.
Er raucht auch ziemlich stark.
Und die Mutter, die hat eine Hüftadrose und hat sonst auch mehrere Knochenbrüche gehabt.
Man spricht bei ihr von brüchigen Knochen.
Mehrere Knochenbrüche?
Ja.
Sie hatte mal den Arm gebrochen, sobald sie hält, bricht sie sich die Knochen.
Und sie hat eine, ihre Knochen sind sehr bruchscherdet.
Aber leidet sie nicht unter Ostoperose.
Die Mutter, das heißt Ostoperose.
Ja, Ostoperose.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, der ist 28 Jahre alt und der hat eine chronische Darmentzündung.
28 Jahre.
Ja.
Und chronische Darmentzündung.
Darmentzündung, ja.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind Lehrerin.
Ja.
Und haben Sie, ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, bin verheiratet und habe eine dreijährige Tochter.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit, Frau Medellus?
Als Lehrerin hat man manchmal schon Stress.
Gerade bei Corona war das sehr anstrengend.
Aber das hat sich jetzt wieder so etwas gebessert im Sommer.
Aber mir macht der Beruf Spaß.
Ja, sehr schön.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Manchmal jogge ich.
Ja, wenn ich Zeit habe, ein bis zweimal die Woche jogge ich, so eine halbe Stunde.
Ja, sehr schön.
Ja, Frau Meyserburg, ich glaube, ihr habt alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, meine Frage ist, was kann das sein? Woran denken Sie?
Ja, Frau Meyserburg, das ist zufüge etwas zu sagen.
Ja, ich habe jetzt alle Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden gesammelt.
Und jetzt danach werden Sie körperlich unterzukommen
und dann diagnostische operative Massnahmen durchführen.
Aber ich habe auch eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Es kann sein, Sie Ihren Blind-Tarm erstründet.
Ja, aber es muss bestätigt werden.
Ja, ich denke, Sie müssen bei uns bleiben.
Darf ich etwas trinken und essen?
Nein, Sie müssen ab jetzt nüchtern sein.
Okay.
Vielleicht es kann sein, wenn unsere Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt werden,
müssen Sie sofort operiert lassen.
Okay, aber Sie machen jetzt erstmal die Untersuchungen.
Ja, in der Zwischenzeit nehmen wir bei Ihnen Blut ab.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen, wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Und dann rufe ich Sie wieder auf.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Kollege gefragt.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind gestellt, aber die Aussage des Patienten
führen uns eine bestimmte Diagnose.
Aber wir müssen unsere differenzialen Diagnostischen Standardfragen stellen.
Ich hatte zwei Fragen.
Ich habe gesagt, wir werden aufgehört.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe langsam.
Wir sind ziemlich langsam angefangen.
Und hatten Sie einen Entwurf frei?
Nein.
Vielleicht die Strahlung können wir fragen.
Strahlung und Schmerzen.
Hab ich nicht verstanden eben.
Welche Frage war das?
Strahlung und Schmerzen.
Jetzt sind Sie rechts unten im Bauch.
Nicht zu trauen, sondern auswanderung.
Anfang waren die Schmerzen um den Bauchnabel rum, in der Mitte.
Da haben Sie begonnen.
Und seit gestern sind Sie gewandert in den rechten Bauch, unter Bauch.
Man kann auch sagen, Sie strahlen in rechten unten.
Nein, am Bauchnabel tut es jetzt gar nicht mehr so gut.
Das tut mir nicht mit dem rechten Unterbauch weh.
Aber Sie strahlen nicht so aus.
Ich hatte ein Ischias vor Jahren.
Und da strahlte der Schmerz aus ins Bein, in den Fuß.
Beim Ischias, beim Bonscheibe.
Das war vor einigen Jahren.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, ja.
Herr Oberarst, haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ich werde über einen neuen Patientin berichten.
Ilona Meselbuk ist 30 Jahre Patientin.
Er ist 1,74 m groß und 63 kg schwer.
Sie stellte sich wegen seit drei Tagen auftreten, drücken,
manchmal krampfartiger Unterbauchschmerzen.
Sie stellte sich vor.
Die Schmerzintensität war bei sieben Liegen.
Bei sieben von zehn Liegen.
Sie berichtete, dass die Schmerzen in der letzten Nacht schlimmer geworden sind.
Machen Sie unterbauch die Schmerzen?
Oder haben Sie sich verändert?
Ja, sie gab auch an.
Die Schmerzen in der Zeit in den Rechten unten gewandert.
Und auch gewandert? Ja, okay.
Und die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten.
Sie teilten mit. Sie haben heute Morgen mit warmen Flächen versucht,
die Schmerzen zu lindern.
Aber das zeigt sich keine Besserung.
Auf Wärme besteht eine gewisse Intoleranz.
Gewisse Intoleranz.
Die Fragen nach Unfall und Ausstrahlung wurden verneint.
Bis auf Neusa, Innerpetenz und Fieber, 83,5.
38,5.
Vor zwei Stunden gemessen.
Wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Das habe ich nicht gefragt.
Ich habe nur, ja, sie haben.
Wichtig zu fragen, wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Noch und für die Anamnese wichtig.
Gut.
Und wann war die letzte Periode?
Ja, ich habe auch nicht gefragt.
Sie hat gesagt, alles in Ordnung.
Und sie waren regelmäßig zum Genakologen.
Gut.
Prima.
Gibt es etwas erwähnenswertes in der Vorgeschichte der Patientin?
Ja.
Seit 15 Jahren.
Seit 15 Jahren leide sie an Hypothrose.
Und dagegen nimmt sie 50 mg morgens.
Und als sie neun Jahre alt, wurde sie Tonselektomie.
Und es ist unverträglich?
Ja, sie kann und er wird unverträglich sein bei ihr bekannt.
Okay.
Ja, in der Familie Anamnese ergaben sich chronische Bronschitis.
Sie OPT beim Vater?
Ja, sie OPT beim Vater.
Und Kokosartrosa und Schwerostoporosa bei der Mutter.
Und chronische und sindische Darmerkrankung.
Und ein Bruder?
Ein Bruder.
Sie sei Lehrerin und sei verheiratet.
Ich habe drei Jahre gesünder Tochter.
Sie treibe regelmäßig Sport.
Und die annamnestischen Angaben.
Nikotin?
Ja, Nikotin und Drogenabosus wurden verneint.
Sie sei dreimal vollständig gegen Covid-19.
Sie war vor zwei Monaten in Italien gewesen.
Okay, gut.
Was ist Ihr Verdachtstiagnose?
Nach bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von der Apotheopandesitis aus.
Die Schmerzlokalisation und alte Gewanderung der Schmerzen
sprechen für die Apotheopandesitis.
Was gibt es von zieldiagnostisch?
Als zieldiagnostisch, kommen in Salfenjettisch oder
als zieldiagnostisch.
Es gibt eine gewisse familiäre Belastung.
Der Bruder hat eine Entzündung?
Es kann auch sein, dass es ein Moduskron sein könnte.
Es könnte sein, ja.
Im Bereich des Terminaleniliums.
Ja, recht der Unterbau.
Ich denke schon, viele Sachen deuten auf eine akute Appendicitis hin.
Die Differenzialdiagnosen haben Sie auch benannt.
Bei der Frau im Bereich der Atmärkse.
Wenn wir nicht klarkommen mit der Appendicitis,
ist das ein gynecologisches Konzil.
Ja, richtig.
Was denken Sie jetzt an Basidiagnostik zu machen?
Ich werde die Patienten körperlicher untersuchen.
Dann würde ich gerne die Appendicitis durchführen.
Ich brauche ein paar Laborparameter wie Entzündungparameter
oder CRPBS.
Gut, bin ich mit einverstanden.
Die Patientin bleibt nüchtern.
Ja.
Richtig, dass sie eine Infusion anhängen.
Sie wird in den letzten Stunden wohl nicht gestern und auch weniger getrunken hat.
Ich bin froh, dass sie da etwas ausgleichen und nichts oral zu sich nimmt.
Gut, bin ich mit einverstanden.
Das haben Sie sehr systematisch gemacht.
Sie haben sich auch durch meine Zwischenfragen nicht aus der Ruhe bringen lassen.
Ich habe die Frage, ob Sie ruhig einfache Sätze machen.
Nicht zu komplizierte Sätze.
Weil die deutsche Grammatik ist manchmal gemein und schwierig.
Einfaches Sätze machen.
Das ist in der Aussagekraft dann manchmal besser.
Das kennen wir schon.
Wenn wir in die Typen wiegen, ja, wir sind nicht draußen.
Aber sonst fand ich das gut.